استثمارات منصات التواصل كثير في الذكاء
الاصطناعي للسنوات وعام 20 23 سيشهدوا
تغييرات كبيره في طريقه ادارتنا لحساباتنا
فورس ودراسات تحليليه اخرى تطبيقات ذكاء
للصناعي سيكون لها سيطره اكبر على محتواك
الخاص تلك التطبيقات يمكنها مراجعه تاريخك
الافتراضي على من الصوت التواصل والحفاظ
على اسلوبك اثناء كتابه محتوى يشبهك قبل
نشره ما يضمن بقائك متصلا مع اصدقائك
وجمهورك دون ان تكتب حرفا واحدا بنفسه في
مجال التسويق على السوشيال ميديا مثلا
يمكن ان يتولى الذكاء الاصطناعي الحملات
الاعلانيه يسمم الصور لنفسه يكتب
التعليقات يروج لها عبر حسابات الشركات
وفقا للجداول زمنيه محدده ويمكنها ايضا
الرد على اسئله العملاء
كيف سيغير ذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هل نتوقع تقنيات
وخيارات جديده متطوره العمل المقبل
لن تكون منصات التواصل الاجتماعي على ما
هي علي الان الحقيقه اكثر ما سوف يتاثر في
مرحله الذكاء الاصطناعي مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اللي هي ثلاث شغلات الشغل
الاولى همم اللي هو محتوى المكتوب انتهى
تماما هذا سوف ينتهي الى غير راجعه ملفات
تعريف الارتباط والان نتحدث عن تقنيات
واللي ملفات الكوكيز التي يدور حولها
دائما شبهات في موضوع الخصوصيه ايضا هذه
سوف تنتهي بشكل كامل الانتقال الى مرحله
الفيديو مرحله المحتوى المعالج من خلال
الذكاء الصناعي بالفيديو هو الذي سوف يكون
مسيطره بالتواصل الاجتماعي العادي
اللي احنا الان بنعيش فيه من خلاله من
جهاز الى جهاز التواصل لكن من خلال الذكاء
الاصطناعي سوف يكون من جهاز الى دماغ بريم
ترامب ديفايس تو برين او من برينت وديبايز
اه حلو
لمرحله التخاطر من خلال برينتو برين
يعني هذا كلام خطير خليني بس انا ابلش معك
الصين طورت الذكاء الاصطناعي لتحديد درجه
ولاء الشخص للحزب الحاكم في الصين
فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن سلاح جديد قادم
ربما قد يكون اخطر من الاسلحه التقليديه
التي نعرفها فهل يجب علينا ان نقلق في
عالم السوشيال ميديا وتوظيف اذا كان
الصناعي معه
انا انا اقول كمستخدمين عرب في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط انا اقول نعم علينا ان نقلق
لان احنا للاسف احنا نستخدم هذه التقنيات
يعني مستهلكين لهذه التقنيات ولسنا همم
مبدعين او خالقين لهذه التقنيات لسنا
مصنعين لها فبالتالي نعم علينا ان نقلق
لانه ما وراء هذه التقنيات الان اكبر
بكثير مما كان على منصات التواصل يعني
بملفات تعريف الارتباط كانوا يلتقطوا
اهتماماتنا من خلال البحث من خلال كلمات
مفتاحيه معينه انتقل المساله الان بالذكاء
الاصطناعي الى مرحله
محاكاه الشعور بمعنى انه باطن الباطن الان
سوف يكون مكشوف مثل هذه التقنيات الان
يعني ومن هون حكيت انا ملفات تعريف
الارتباط الى حيث لا رجعه لانه الخصوصيه
انتهت بشكل كامل مع وجود منصات اييي
تخدمها الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]